foreign
[Music]
hello everybody
hello hello hello
thank you to everybody for being here
I know we all just want to talk about
Wolverine right
we don't even want to talk about
She-Hulk tonight right we just want to
talk about Wolverine
yo yo yo yo yo yo what's up everybody
what's up Wolverine wrg you're probably
happy that oh the the news
yeah I dyed my hair even uh
even lighter
uh how many episodes of She-Hulk are
there there are nine to my knowledge
yeah nice what up
yeah Wolverine y'all oof what is this
noise oh League of Legends is open in
the background once I'm gonna let me
close this out
and there we go
little
bitlas
are you in Florida right there hello
Christopher Salazar hold on let me go
Stars
uh
uh glad I didn't notify you late Archer
thank you Lone Wolf uh I don't think
Daredevil is going to be in this one
y'all I think Daredevil is an episode
eight
as sad as that is and it's really sad
hello hello
yeah I'm I'm so
unbelievably unbelievably pumped
for Hugh Jackman I mean
I mean oh
hey Mr Henderson what's going on
uh some people sing the volumes low
nothing's really different
let's see uh let's take a look at the
the YouTubes here
uh
let's listen to this audio
Mr Anderson what do we think of the
audio how are we doing
sounds good to me
so here's my question here's my question
who has like already deciphered
what they said when they were you know
who's like read their lips already
that's that's my question has anybody
figured out what they were really saying
I know
what was it
oh I think he said you're gonna effing
love it he's like you're
I think that's what Hugh Jackman I think
that's like one of the last things he
said before he was like thank you Kevin
feige so
yeah
Curtis Warren I like your name
I'm at work at my fire station in
Florida working through the hurricane
right now where in Florida do you live
because I used to live in Orlando my
brother-in-law still lives there and he
was a firefighter
you tried hella hard to do what did I
miss a comment
s
I don't see it I feel like I missed your
coming
but welcome everybody welcome welcome
welcome welcome yeah I don't
um
I don't foresee
I I've I've heard Daredevil isn't and
this one I hear he's an eight maybe
we'll get like frog man or
oh that's what you were talking about
Cole uh you tried really hard to lip
read gotcha gotcha gotcha yeah yeah okay
I see it now yeah yeah uh
yeah Chris actually I was talking to him
earlier and
um
he we were in like Discord together and
then he's like oh and he was on this
phone the Wi-Fi went out and then the
power went out and he's like oh there it
is
so that sucks uh vulture blocks thank
you for being sub for so long I really
appreciate that
Deadpool Wolverine need to be in secret
Warriors hey if you caught my video I
did yesterday kind of like talking about
the whole thing I really believe that
Hugh will show up in secret Wars I mean
why not like what is what is Secret Wars
for if not
the infinite possibility of cameos now
we thought this about Wolverine or
Wolverine uh Multiverse Madness right
and
we didn't get it I don't I don't uh I
don't want to go through them
it's really weird like I don't want to
have the mindset of we're gonna get a
ton of cameos but like that's what
secret Wars is like
you know so it's like
I should be able to expect it
but at the same time it's like
well I don't want to be let down
I don't want to be let down so
yeah
uh yeah I mean
what should my favorite team up Deadpool
with MCU character like who would I like
to see I mean Wolverine I mean we're
getting it right
um
Wolverine and just
Spider-Man right because that's iconic
that's classic
um
thank you for being subbed for for over
a year I appreciate that so much thank
you thank you to everybody who's who's
up to the channel really
thank you to Mr Anderson for being here
being a great mod he has a channel as
well he'll he'll link that if you guys
want to show him some love uh how do we
feel about Scarlet Witch tease yeah you
know I I knew she wasn't dead they that
that red light's so intentional is the
thing right I mean
you you we saw that red light as
everything was falling it's just like
okay what like what is that like her
dying like no it's just
that's not what it is Yo Jonathan Cahoon
remember in the chat are we expecting a
second one kind of forever trailer
before it comes out oh yeah totally oh
yeah yeah
actually what did they like officially
what did they officially title that did
they actually call it a teaser
what did they do
uh yeah so they called it a teaser so we
will get an official trailer for sure
yeah
yeah
Marcus what's up man welcome welcome
coming in every week
uh Arthur Day comedy performing from the
comics or the movies because it's not
yeah no
um
it's funny because you know Iron Man
really wasn't a popular character in the
comics like the movie really I think
made him
this like iconic
character
you know
um
and I almost want to say
I I prefer him in the MCU for what him
and like Robert Downey Jr portraying him
did right like to start it all off
you're right they're very different
uh how long the episode comes out I
would say exactly 10 minutes from now
they usually drop them at oh speaking of
Let's uh pull up Disney plus and get
that ready huh because I believe we
still have figured out our little hack
of how to share the screen
Sue hello
I'm good how are you did you survive
your uh
uh was it a typhoon or a monsoon I don't
remember which one it which one it was
uh Marvel
She-Hulk I'm tired y'all
Avatar VFX 13 years old is way better
than She-Hulk yeah
uh it starts
and I would say nine minutes now all
right so let me see something right
quick
how do I
nope nope nope nope go back go back why
can't I hear this okay so can you all
see this oh
you know what hold on don't worry
it's because I was not using Chrome
I have to use Chrome okay
if I use Chrome
then I could show some of it on the
screen
I know that I know that because Chrome
is where I figured out the little trick
you wanted to like okay this is like the
most annoying thing to me here I'll pull
up my screen for this
I don't know why this annoys me so much
see how I hover over this right here if
you hover over the actual Marvel logo
you cannot click on this you have to
click around it and I don't know why
that's so frustrating to me
it's so frustrating hey vulture Fox
thank you for uh the Super Chat I saw
your comment earlier as well you've been
subbed over a year thank you so much
uh okay hold on does does this work can
you see this
boom yes okay
so instead of the timer today I'll just
show random parts of the episode
uh uh there oh yeah for people for
people uh asking to see a few more
comments uh since we started
um
uh one pixel Pig thank you for being a
new subscriber there should be Nine
episodes of She-Hulk I believe they cut
the tenth one
um the episode starts in about seven
minutes for those asking
um
and Jonathan gahoon thoughts on blade
losing the director so close film
starting movie gets pushed back to 2024.
yeah I mean they should have the same
script which is a concern because
mahershala Ali does not like the script
apparently they're two fight scenes
um and they're pretty lackluster so I
just I kind of hope they just change it
all if they need to delay it they should
because blade is a movie that I want
done right
I want that movie Done Right Also let's
talk about how Ryan Reynolds was in the
Blade trilogy there's gotta be a
Deadpool joke there somewhere like
Deadpool has to team up with blade and
make a joke at some point in time I mean
it writes itself right JD Ultra what is
going on Jeff flake's K-pop in the chat
what's going on that's what I'm going
for that's what I'm going for the hair
there we go pull it back more
uh I don't think mahershala Ali is going
to drop out I I'm not really concerned
with that
I I
just think that he wants it to be a good
movie and he's expressed his concerns
about it not being a committee
yeah
do you think Galactus will ever make an
appearance on the MCU yes I do I think
it's gonna be after this phase is the
thing
warm pop Marcus that's funny
uh but yeah for for those asking about
uh
uh blade yeah apparently there was uh
only two fight scenes and they weren't
that good
so I hope they change I really how can
you have like how can you have a blade
movie and only have two fight scenes it
doesn't make sense
like it doesn't make sense at all
uh
yeah I mean Arthur there was a
I'm not I don't actually know why
I and I guess we don't really ever know
why they decide to kind of change
Origins right and and not and um like I
don't want to say beliefs but kind of
with with Iron Man yeah
um it's just the direction they started
to go
what's going on guys
yeah blade should just be consistent
fight scenes uh just non-stop swords
freaking cutting freaking vampires up
yeah um
Chaz do you think the thing rumors true
uh
I thought it made sense but now I'm
I'm not holding my breath for that
because we haven't seen Daredevil yet I
don't think we're gonna see him tonight
if we were to see the thing I think it
would be the last episode
I think it would be like
I think it would be something like at
the at the very end they'd be like are
you ready for your next client and then
it's like oh it's the thing it's been
Grimmer the thing you know
hmm oh
Jonathan you make uh you make a good
point uh the whole Black Knight you know
eternals post credit that makes sense
Red Man's Land what's going on
welcome welcome and thank you for that
thank you for that appreciate that
uh Gabriel there's a
there's a lip reading on IGN we'll have
to check that out let's check it out uh
Mr Anderson what do you think the last
uh the lot of people at the end of
She-Hulk
um I think it's what was his name
Lucas was that his name
the the Baywatch guy
um I think he's oh what was it called
was it Hulk
not hookling oh I can't remember
it's like a group of Hulks
I think they're gonna try to you know
get her blood
to make Hawks oh I'm so tired y'all ugh
I've been up very early and did not take
a nap which I normally try to do
uh before these live
parties because you know they run late
tonight uh Berkus Thompson what's going
on we share the same last name
you know the Joshi was it Josh was it
Todd I
I
Luke Jacobson that's what I that's
that's
oh my gosh who is it I'm just gonna look
it up oh my gosh
oh my gosh you're killing me come on
come on Google
I thought it was Lucas
what did I say it was
it's Todd okay it is Todd
I swear it said something else
I swear it said something else but it is
taught okay it is done uh
guys that starts in two minutes I
believe and I I do do not hold your
breath for Daredevil
just just don't I don't think he's gonna
be in this episode I
if I'm wrong great but I I think it's an
episode eight not this episode I
wouldn't hold your breath really
um for those asking if I'm excited for
She-Hulk episode seven
I want to be but I'm scared I feel like
She-Hulk had a lot of potential and
myself personally I'm not really liking
the direction that it's gone the past
couple of episodes totally redeemable I
think it started out really strong and I
think it's kind of falling off I hope it
picks back up
uh do you think MC or X-Men Quicksilver
will come back in secret Wars uh why not
both
right why not both
I think that's what it's uh I think
that's what it's for
fairness squads of supreme and Loki
season two uh I heard that rumor I did
hear that rumor we'll see if it's true
uh 12 49.
it is not out yet
should be on a one minute oh
I'm very tired
uh I
y'all don't I know y'all I'll say
holding your breath and maybe I'm wrong
but I have heard it's episode eight
granted the person who said it
did say things could change
but
uh bimbo ah gotcha so Instagram's really
weird
um for starters I have like a thousand
messages on Instagram so I just don't
reply to them because there are just so
many I'm sorry but it also doesn't
notify me of messages
um unless I'm following somebody back
Instagram and Twitter both do that they
kind of like filter off into uh
I can't remember what it's called
something so I don't typically
uh read them I I reply to a lot on
Twitter so if you have a it's where you
can uh
tweet at me uh coach um keynote nope
don't think Daredevil today I really
don't I'm hoping but I don't I think
it's episode eight but it's out so we're
gonna do this so we're gonna do this
thing
The Retreat yeah
I just feel like Abominations in this I
feel like it's not gonna be
yeah I just really feel like this isn't
gonna be it y'all
today we're already like
we're we're already diving into uh
a meal and he's already you know
he's the Cameo I think this you know
I don't I don't think it's gonna
oh that's Josh
that's Josh no I was like there's a Josh
in the film right or in the in the show
right
uh watermelon Sprite uh I told Tyrone he
can react my videos that's that's all
him man
real rejects do it too and you know
I don't think Daredevil's coming y'all
right now we're just kind of going
through this but uh I think I think
today is the um
I think we're getting a uh Emile Blonsky
Abomination Cameo today I think that's
what's uh happening does it say why does
it say
I'm trying to check the stream here it's
not uh
it's not working out
why isn't this working
now it's worked okay good
can't wait to see you Josh
[Music]
I can't read sideways
so she's getting ready for a date it
looks like I think
yes
yes getting ready for the date
well that's interesting
it's like a time lapse of her
getting ready for the date
I like the beat to this song but I I
don't like
I don't I don't I don't like like the
feel of it Josh look at this guy I like
him a lot I really hope he's not bad I'm
really hoping Josh is not bad
oh they're having a good time
yo she
about to pull him in
oh he went for the handshake she went
for the hug and it was awkward
foreign
oh they're like texting a lot
and she's happy gosh that's CGI
I can't with the CGI
well the major league you are in this
time
oh going in for it no
is she gonna leave
no oh
why didn't she kiss him
oh
why did she kiss him she went back out
and he was gone already
I feel like I've been like a million
dates why aren't you oh oh driving movie
how cute is that
go for it Josh did it oh this guy
uh we are
why isn't tell me how far we're in it we
are three minutes and and 45 seconds
into it
oh he went in
he went in everybody
he went in there we go
sealed the deal Josh and uh
almost said Tatiana that's her real name
um
Jennifer are absolutely he's gone I bet
she went to get her breakfast or
something though
did you leave her a note oh oh oh that
was fun
I can't stop smiling
Josh you better not dip I swear Josh
come on Josh
oh no
they slept together and now he's gone
hey Leon Haley thanks so much for
becoming a member
thanks so much we I super appreciate
that
welcome welcome welcome
hey Amanda welcome welcome
uh yes Arthur I am uh I'm excited for
all this
dude I'm saying there's no reason in
today's time to not
reply to a text within like a few hours
oh no it's Saturday it's been a whole
day and he hasn't texted her back did he
really get what he wanted and then
bailed that's not that Josh I know
gee looks She's going kind of crazy
though oh no
I'm still I'm not holding my breath for
Daredevil this episode y'all
she's watching them the Muppets on her
phone
I know it's her TV now it changed from
her phone to do
oh maybe he did get her blood boom and
JoJo maybe that's what it was guys I had
this feeling like he was bad but now I
feel like he's not for some reason
it's not gonna be from him
you ho Josh or a hoe
I mean oh it's Sunday and he hasn't
replied
foreign
no who is this
oh Mayo blonsky's parole officer
yikes
that whack a dude ranch
so she has to go She-Hulk
my head itches
I'm not expecting Daredevil today off
uh the chair I'm sitting on is from and
deceit
and a seat you can buy them online
oh he still hasn't
Bop
I haven't heard that song In Forever
summer Twilights is the is the resort
oh that I finally cracked it but
ah
he said get up put on your green suit
get get green
because he's the Abomination
oh
oh he's normal
he's here
princess silk feather
he says he hit an electric fence but
I don't think so
so this is just they're just you know
doing this
oh
here here's this scene that we saw
earlier today Marvel released the scene
before
uh she just freaking wiped the floor of
these guys
it is cool how she can go back and forth
between her Hulk self and regular self
man bull
this is interesting
ishwash Buckler
foreign
they did destroy her car whoops
you're a lawyer you can get money from
them
my name's man bull not mechanical
oh that's nice look at that
that's nice
his wives must be rich man or his soul
mates I guess they're not married maybe
they got married
Pickens he was talking about
well you can't so
all right we better find out what's up
with Josh in this episode I'm gonna be
pissed
but no Wi-Fi
oh
this hat this isn't how I wanted to
spend my day and he says this is maybe
that's how you needed to spend your day
I like that
uh Leon Haley uh can I buy pizza for Mr
Anderson yes I could buy pizza for Mr
Anderson
um
yes absolutely I've actually what did I
buy that one time Mr Anderson a couple
movie tickets and
food and drinks for the movie
next next movie you have to remind me to
do that again
for being the best mod
so she's just trying to get service
around this result resort resort
and just walk it around
and just can't get service
yeah don't ex don't expect Daredevil
this is the wood cabin they were talking
about
oh
no service she's gonna get service all
of a sudden
service oh
they're in the little
look at
thinks he's a vampire oh
Alejandro struggled
[Laughter]
Spanish is a language not a nationality
you've never heard of Spain that's funny
oh
um
oh
no
wonder
who porcupine is
is he gonna take a suit off
oh he's not taking his suit off
wait do we know this guy is one of the
guys that attacked her
it is right
she's breaking the fourth wall
he previously on yep I knew it it's that
guy
so he's here now that's interesting
oh she pissed
she big bad
sit in the comment chair
so this guy was in The Wrecking Crew and
now
and now what
a magic crowbar to give him a false
sense of power
you are a super villain
he says sorry
oh they're calling her out they said she
needs to work on herself
I want to know who porcupine is I want
to know who it is
what's up Malik what's going on
oh she's talking about him she's talking
about Josh
had sex
but
they're making
they're making them switch seats because
they're so codependent on each other
oh
that is thirsty and a clear cliche own
dad jokes
oh she texted them again
oh
oh
blushing smile emoji
or he wanted your blood he probably
wanted her blood
oh
that she hoped to Gin oh that's sad
who's from the X-Men Leon I I don't know
who you're talking about right now I
missed the conversation
no I'm so sad
um
that's a bummer
oh yeah I just want I want to know who
like the actor is displaying him I
wonder who it like it is
hey Chris Jones thanks so much
appreciate that
so you're just talking about how good it
felt for somebody to actually like Jen
and not She-Hulk
let's kill him okay I don't want to kill
him that's funny
just made an enemy of the entire group
whoa he's got lightning that comes out
of a sword
by electricity
hmm
hahaha
hmm
yeah they did Marcus
oh she's gonna turn back in the Gin now
are they gonna like attack her right
away to get her blood
oh she's gin now but are they gonna
attack her and get her blood
oh sport you're probably gonna take it
off
also is he a bad guy
hey
they rejected him
oh they told him to delete Josh's number
that's hard to do
that's hard to do
oh she deleted his number
oh that you're got it she's in the air
no and she's in uh
normal clothes
we made this for you
we love Jen and she Oak
oh and Dua Lipa plays
wait
oh no I thought she was driving the the
tow truck
three days earlier What's Happening Here
all right
oh
okay so she's asleep
he's getting dressed
he's gonna like take like a sample of
her hair or blood or something
oh he's copying her phone I knew Josh
was bad
I absolutely knew Josh was bad
Eddie took a picture of her
look at that
he and he texted Hulk King saying that
he got her blood and there it is
is there anything to look
at in these credits
I don't think is really anything to look
at in the credits here
it looks like just a normal credits that
roll
matadorian jiffy
that's a family dinner
and this is nothing
I see a shield folder but that's been in
every episode so is this shot right here
so I'm starting to think
and that's it
okay
and that's it
this episode could have been
three minutes long
like literally
it could have been like five minutes
long
that's funny oh I have this is Kyrie
today
that's Kyrie Rocket's right here she is
sleeping
foreign
was fun
it was a fun episode and it was fine it
was like a standalone thing on its own
I'm just I am really disappointed at the
lack of Direction with the show
and I knew Josh was a bad guy I knew it
I called it last week I was like I I
just knew it I was like it's too good
right it's too good to be true
uh
I I think
yes I do buy comics
um Leon
was it better than live in last week's
per maybe a little bit
I didn't like
it's not that I I that I didn't enjoy
the episode I enjoyed watching it like
it was a good time because I'm here with
you guys as a watch party but like it's
weak writing I'm sorry it's it's
and like yeah Mr Ennis what you said the
lesson she shared about wanting to be
better in high school and then finding
out what it was like was great like that
was like it was good as far as like
how do I explain this
it was that's just good it's a good life
like advice
but the show to me
the writing is terrible
I'm just I'm just gonna say it
um it's just
bad writing to me
as as an overall
like story arc there is none
they've teased us a few times with like
these villains but like there's two
episodes left now and we don't truly
know who the villain is we have our
guesses and assumptions
but like say you're not like us
say you're not you know staying up at
midnight 2 am 3 AM whatever time it is
for you and you just normally watch the
show
do you have zero idea
because we look into this
so it's not that this isn't
it's not like this isn't like
not like they're not showing us
enjoyable things right because there
were enjoyable moments in this episode
there were there were enjoyable moments
in the last episode right there's always
enjoyable moments but
people keep saying and I understand I
understand like people keep saying like
view each episode as its own thing I
can't because that's not what Marvel
does so
Marvel's trying to go out of the norm of
what they normally do but like
with everything else they haven't so
they're asking us to do something we've
never really done before with a really
important character
and yeah Mr Anderson you have a fair
point you have a fair point if we all
use some radical acceptance and realize
that situational comedy and not a Hulk
smash show I think we might enjoy it
more the only thing
I I just uh I just I don't think that's
how they set up the show I really don't
I don't think that's uh
how they set it up they oh we they
talked about a lot of action and they
still do and like the trailers that they
show like they they didn't Market the
show right they didn't really uh
set our expectations for what it was
supposed to be
I think there should have been a better
job doing that I actually don't think I
I I think
I I think they should have put more time
into the show actually
like She-Hulk is a great character and I
was really excited to see She Hulk and I
I still think her future is bright
because she can appear in other things
and who knows maybe the next two
episodes would be amazing
there was this was like enjoyable I
enjoyed these moments I I liked watching
all of the people in the circle talk and
say they wanted to go kill Josh that was
funny
um
that was funny
but this is like a show about jyn
discovering who she is
you know what I mean
and
yeah I just feel like this is this is uh
more so a show about Jen
yeah
I don't know I just I don't see much
Direction in it and I and I to me that's
just really throwing me off now
see a Darkness into the wind
should have got more time I feel like
episodes are really short I feel like I
feel like they should have just
I feel like they should have just given
her more time and they could have done
like stuff like this but then added some
more stuff to it
thank you Emmanuel Lara
um
yeah I just I I had I mean maybe go
frenzy Maybe
to me I think they should have given the
show more time
and when I mean more time I mean like
more time in the writing room
more time to work on you know CGI and
stuff but that doesn't you know a lot of
people talk about CJ that doesn't really
bug me that much like
we know it's not real right like I mean
we know it's not real right so what do
we yeah I I
feel like if they actually would have
set up the show
like if they would have more clearly
defined what the show was going to be I
feel like a lot of people wouldn't have
a problem with it like really like if
they described it as just like this very
light-hearted uh you know show that's
meant to be like a like you know like a
sitcom that's most that's supposed to
like enjoy each into like each episode
individually for what that episode is
I feel like a lot of people would
actually really like the show
I think the people who can view it that
way do really like the show and I think
that's where you know those people come
in who everyone's like I love the show I
think they you know like Mr Anderson
viewing the show each episode for what
it is on its own
and that's that's great I just wish they
would have kind of like
prepped us for that like told us like
I just wish they would have like
told us what to do with our expectations
but to me the marketing it kind of seems
like they shoved Daredevil down our
throats not shoved it down our throats
but like you can't show Daredevil and
you know not expect people just to be
expecting Daredevil all the time and
they literally stay in the trailers like
it's full of action so I'm like huh
interesting
yeah it's uh
hmm
it's uh
it's had some good parts for me
and it's hard for me to really like
I'm not sure I've ever said I hated
something
like a show or movie or something like
that that wasn't like a horror or
something like that so I don't hate the
show by any means and I can sit here
watch it and enjoy myself
especially now
um
I can now
I I now can sit back and go I shouldn't
expect
like these big story things like I mean
I I guess now you should because it's
like the final episodes but if I had the
mindset in like episode three that I
have now I feel like I would have
enjoyed it more
right I think we just need to kind of
level our expectations out and just
realize that like the show is not what
we thought it was going to be it is what
it is let's take it in for what it is
from here on out
and we do get the Daredevil Cameo and
that'll be fun and maybe we'll get
another cool Cameo and maybe we can you
know all the people are really hating
the show could just enjoy the show uh
and accept it for what it is from the
final two episodes
um but as far as like the overall
direction of the uh series is going
um
I I don't like it
you know I just
I don't like it anymore I did like it at
first
um I feel like the first I like the
first episode I like the second episode
I like the fourth episode I don't think
I like the third one
um
yeah
I'm a bit disappointed but I uh
you know and and and to to to it was
also labeled as a a lawyer show
did we even see her in court the past
two episodes I honestly don't remember
the last oh no it's just the it was just
the
um
uh the wedding
right no court I guess we did see
I guess last episode we did see the
whole Mr Immortal thing
so there's a little bit of a law there
um
to me I just think
um
it lacks Direction it could use
a little bit better right I mean it
could use better right I'm not going to
sugarcoat that I don't like the writing
I'm just it's not what I I like
chihoka's character this is not what I
expected so again I go back to I kind of
blame Marvel not for like what the show
is but
for marketing it in a very wrong way I
think it was just I don't think it was
marketed in the right way at all
that too Jeff
I and I I think I mentioned that if if
Daredevil wasn't teased
and I think people would
be enjoying it more
um
yeah
I think just I think at this point now
in all honesty it's like
I think this show and some other shows
and some things to come are going to be
good examples of
what to expect for Marvel and I mean
this in uh
uh in a neutral way not like in a bad
way or or necessarily like a good way I
think overall will be good but like we
have to realize that you know before
Marvel Studios was releasing
two three movies a year
and now
you know four movies a year
five six Disney Plus
shows it's a lot right and it's not all
gonna be the same
because you can't just do the same thing
forever right eventually people will get
tired of the same formula right whether
we want to admit that or not
and I'm sure there are people kind of
like myself we could kind of watch this
stuff all day but you know you do have
to come up with fresh ideas
again I just think the writing could be
better and the expectations should have
been made clear
that's all
I think the expectation should have been
made clear
um
and I think the people who came in with
no expectations
are enjoying the show because people do
enjoy the show yes a lot of people don't
like the show
but some people are enjoying the show
and I think those people are the ones
who kind of are like yeah I'll watch it
I'll see what it's about and they're
just chilling and they're just like yeah
cool but for us
you know
a lot of us disappointed because it's
not what we thought it was going to be
anyone else think the Matador was Kate
Bishop's stepdad at first I was like yo
it's my guy then he took off the mass DJ
wave D
um no but now that uh now that you said
that I'm surprised I didn't think that
yeah exactly Mr Anderson phase four uh
uh it is
diverging from
what the norm of the MCU is and I think
this is uh like a test for Marvel and I
also think it's like preparation for us
like Marvel's trying to prep us for like
a bunch of different things because like
I said like there's like six Disney plus
projects coming out every year I don't
think that's gonna change do I think
they should slow it down yes
I think they should focus on quality not
quantity
so
so yeah
I don't know you know I I don't think I
don't think it's you know
it's not something I would not watch and
I you know I get it if you hate it you
hate it you know I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna tell you to change your mind you
feel how you feel and if you love it you
love it again you know don't let people
change your mind you know like feel your
feelings
feel your feelings you know uh I just
think
I'm gonna go in casually to the next two
episodes thinking like hey Daredevil's
gonna be in it that's going to be fun
and maybe there'll be some other fun
scenes and hey maybe they'll set up a
villain for you know Captain America new
world order or something like that you
know I think that's the attitude we have
to have going into it if you want to
someone enjoy the show uh but I'm not
gonna lie and say I've been super
enjoying it I I've had a fine time
sitting here watching it I've had some
good moments watching it I've had some
Chuckles it's not my favorite thing it
definitely is a lower list like a lower
tier you know Marvel Studios project for
me
um
but hey
we don't have to like everything
you know
I just yeah I see I see I see uh
I see a lot of people uh
saying you know the quality
over quantity thing yeah and you know I
just
I just think that's that's what they
need to do
they need to you know like again I don't
think the sea Jet doesn't bug me I just
think like it there are some parts for
this bad it doesn't bug me but
they should have more like it shouldn't
be bad you know what I'm saying like
instead of having six Disney blushes you
should have four that way more money and
more time goes into them and the quality
will improve
thank you Leo
uh yeah so I mean
for those who seemingly are like losing
faith in Marvel again they're so they're
producing so much more than they
normally have been producing right
you're not gonna like everything but I
mean Deadpool 3 was just announced and
Hugh Jackman is coming back as Wolverine
we have the Fantastic Four coming you
know uh there's
there's a lot exciting stuff happening
thoughts about episode should I watch it
yeah totally roaring lion let me totally
watch it
I would always watch everything all the
you know I would always watch every
Marvel Disney Plus show if you're a fan
of the MCU yeah even if something
similarly doesn't connect you know it
will at some point in time so we think
right
so
Jonathan Cahoon yeah that's you know
they took some big risks and and a swing
and a miss for some uh
uh yeah I mean
I did a poll
I'm curious let me
I did a poll what last week or something
after
last week's episode what did that end up
coming to
uh I I did a poll you know what are your
thoughts on She-Hulk it's got 50 000
votes
and I said it's great it's good it's
okay it sucks
11 said it's great 19 said it's good
41 said it's okay and 29 said it sucks
so about 70 of the people are either
really enjoying it or think it's at
least okay
so but
Jason the villain really smashed
chickpets took blood and yeah
uh don't expect I see I saw some uh
I saw some people talking about the
thing guys don't expect that just
please I don't know if it's gonna happen
or not that was a rumor that was going
around don't expect it because if you
expect that I you're gonna be most
likely disappointed and that's gonna
make you not like this show even more
please don't expect that
please don't expect that
um
but yeah I mean here it even says you
know about 70 of the people are fine
with it at the very least right 41 said
it's okay
19 said it's good 11 said it's great you
know it's the 30 saying it sucks and I
understand both sides I really do try
try to be open-minded have your own
opinion but we don't need to tear other
people down for me it's not it's a miss
the show's kind of a Miss for me and
it's sad because it started off good in
my opinion and I'm holding out
I'm holding out for the final two shows
or episodes I really am it could redeem
itself right we had some Filler episodes
but maybe they just needed to fill some
stuff until like a pretty you know big
final two episodes I mean Daredevil's
gonna be in one of them and Chantix
loves the show see there you go
there you go and Chantix loves Joe and
welcome enchant tricks I think I missed
you last week I apologize I like went
through the live stream after
um and I saw that you were like hey I'm
here and I was like oh I missed that I'm
so sorry but I got you this week I got
you this week
yeah
take it for what it is you know
um
take it for what it is now we know how
it is now uh I somehow gym my finger
sorry it just really hurts that's about
jammed my finger
um
I actually do think it was better than
the last episode I I feel like the last
episode really
was a filler episode and this one
pretty much was too but I think I
enjoyed it more in the last episode
it is kind of funny that they teased us
with the Daredevil
helmet mask
two episodes ago
they re I see to me that shows
that Marvel kind of knew these next two
episodes were where kind of
filler like they knew it
right
because they they gave us that tease to
make us stick through these two episodes
I feel
those clever people
yeah I think this was very
um
is it accurate to say that this is
Marvel's first attempt at a true comedy
is that
is that accurate to say that this is
Marvel's attempt at an actual comedy
have they done that before
I mean ant-man's like a comedy right but
it's still got a lot of serious stuff to
it
yeah wouldn't that be funny if Daredevil
never showed up wouldn't that be funny
I'd be I'd be pissed obviously
but
but wouldn't that be
wouldn't that be you know
I think that would be funny yeah I I
think that now Guardians is really funny
as well yeah but this is but this is
like
this is like sitcom comedy right that's
what they went for this is that's what
they went for like sitcom comedy and
this is their first attempt at that and
it's it seemingly is missing with a you
know a good percentage of people
yeah I
I would I wouldn't have teased Daredevil
I really wouldn't have I think
yeah I wouldn't have teased Daredevil
that would have been like
now that I think about it
now that I think about it they really
teased Daredevil because they I really
feel like they thought people were gonna
fall off from watching the show
actually I actually believe that because
I'm thinking like why would you tease
that like
like
that would have been a huge surprise
like crazy huge like you know what I
mean
yes Mr Anderson
that's kind of how I feel about She-Hulk
now like I've said you know before but
there's a lot of new people in the
Stream right now I all right let's not
spam people you get timed out if you
spam
um
this show is marketed the wrong way and
it was promoted the wrong way and it
showed Daredevil when it shouldn't have
showed Daredevil
they should have just waited for that to
be you know an awesome Cameo surprise
you know and the final
two episodes one episode whatever it's
gonna be you know they
they marketed it wrong
they should have marketed Market did it
as a sitcom comedy
they should have done a promotion with
like Kevin feige talking behind the
scenes about how this is something
extremely different than the anything
they've ever done before you know
and and that would have like been like
okay cool I think a lot of people would
have at least
maybe not expected anything because they
wouldn't have known what to expect going
in you know what I mean and that would
have leveled the expectations and then
you don't have
uh the whole Daredevil thing hanging
above everybody's head expecting you
know
that coming you know him coming in and
you know like first episode second
episode and you know it's funny because
you know
uh
it's funny because like from the very
first episode everyone's like I saw the
first four before they came out and
everyone's like you know where's
Daredevil where's dared about I'm like I
haven't seen Daredevil yet so
yeah I just think it was kind of
marketed wrong
which is unfortunate who knows what uh
what this could have been who knows how
people could have actually
uh like enjoyed it who knows what they
would have actually thought about it
um
if it was marketed kind of
the right way
so
yeah
um
let's see if this redeems itself
um
I'm disappointed in the last
three episodes
this was seven right yeah I'm just
pointing last three episodes
um
I feel like it started strong
and I liked it
and uh this is this is uh
to me it's going down uh I'm just gonna
do it for what it is from now on I uh
I'm gonna enjoy it for what it is from
now on
um I'm expected just to be like the
sitcom comedy and not too much big stuff
happening even Daredevil showing up I'm
gonna expect I'm just gonna act like
he's only in it for a minute because
then I won't be disappointed
um
yeah so we'll see we'll see what it sets
up we'll see you know what actually
happens I'm I'm
mad at Josh
I knew he was bad I called it last
episode I knew he was bad
uh
yeah
yeah yeah I don't know where the next
Black Panther trailer is it should
definitely be here we're about a month
away from the movie so
yeah
yeah
um
I I don't think I'll
re-watch this ever
just to be perfectly honest
but I'm really happy for the people who
are enjoying the show that's really
awesome like if you're vibing with the
show if you're liking it if you think
it's funny and you think it's
light-hearted and you're just chilling
good
that's how I'm gonna try to be for the
next couple episodes you know
uh
yeah but uh yeah jaquel Booker the show
isn't how you pictured it at all and
that's what I think the problem is for
the people who aren't enjoying it
but I do kind of put that on Marvel they
didn't Market it the right way they
marketed it as an action show they
continued to say it's got action in it
in the trailers
um they marketed it as like a law show
and
you know it it's not really a law show
like if you ever watched a true law show
it's nothing like that
um
I just it's smart it was marketed bro
that's all
um
it was just marketed wrong so let's have
you know
low expectations about the final two
episodes let's just go in thinking like
hey it's going to be you know kind of a
light-hearted fun time it's a comedy uh
we'll expect some you know comedy in it
and Daredevil's gonna show up and
that'll be cool and they'll set up a
villain and uh yeah there you go I think
that's it
I think that's it that's all there is to
it you know
and there you go
there it is so all right everybody I uh
yes exactly Mr Anderson like people like
I put it on Marvel they the marketing
should have been better they should have
gave they should have told us what to
expect that's all
so hey Marvel's experimenting with new
things uh some is going to be amiss for
some people but hey sub's gonna be like
a knock out of the park for some people
too so there's gonna be good and bad
with that right
um so hey all right I'm I'm logging out
I'm tired my eyes are barely open uh
I'll be
I'm not gonna lie I don't think this
episode of warrants a breakdown there's
not much to it actually no it does
because of the people in the in the
circle and everything like that yeah
yeah thank you Emmanuel I appreciate
that
yeah I'm not trying to hit on the show I
just you know I'm not gonna lie I'm not
enjoying it so much I don't want to hate
on it by by any means at all I just you
know it's it's a lower ranking
you know show for me oh thank you jaquel
I super appreciate that Super Chat
um
all right I am logging out guys uh thank
you so much for joining the stream today
I really do appreciate it thank you Mr
Anderson uh always have your work cut
out for you
um I get it people get passionate about
shows but thank you for being being a
mod
um Chad thank you so much
I I do enjoy these live streams uh they
get hard but I do because I'm so tired
but I do enjoy these live streams thank
you for stopping by thank you for
chatting thank you for the super chats
and you know I always say thank you for
the people you just watch because I do
appreciate you too thank you
um you you could be somewhere else right
now but you're here
uh there was an Easter egg Justice phone
Bruce Thompson I'm going to check that
out thank you so much for telling me
that I am obviously going to go over the
episode again and do a breakdown uh
after I wake up tomorrow all right I
really am getting tired I can feel my
eyes uh uh
like really closing my voice is like
going away now so I'm hitting the bed
um
but we'll be back here next week for the
second to last episode and uh
yeah
I'll just see you guys next time love
you all very much and